cela aussi fait aujourd'hui le 325e
anniversaire de sa marine un événement
qui sera célébré en grand pompe à saint
pétersbourg notamment avec un défilé des
plus beaux navires de la marine russe
les détails avec notre correspondant en
plein coeur à l'occasion du jour de la
marine est ce comme chaque année saint
pétersbourg va accueillir la grande
parade militaire navale sur les flots de
la neva le fleuve qui traverse la cité
impériale au programme donc défini de
nombreux bâtiments de guerre russes
corvette frégates sous-marins et autres
embarcations
à noter également la présence de navires
militaires étrangers puis il y aura
aussi la traditionnelle
adresse du président russe aux marins en
ouverture de cette parade navale voilà
ce que l'on peut dire sur le programme
je vous retrouverai tout au long de
cette matinée pour vous faire vivre au
plus près les festivités